citizens of the reject Nation we are
headed back once more into the further
Greg and John here for insidious the red
door chapter five are you excited sir
yes I have only seen the first two once
but we sat down to read the plot
descriptions in detail together John
right we did I remember everything now
it's as if you just saw the movie fresh
10 minutes ago well guys leave a like
for good research and also subscribe to
the channel and hit the notification
Bell to learn when we have more
reactions for you guys to consume thanks
to the folks at prepper for cutting
these highlights down it's tough work
and we'd appreciate and admire them for
it and last but not least if you want to
join us for the entire Insidious The Red
Door experience receive every bit of
content that doesn't make these reaction
highlights come on over to patreon.com
the real read Jack sync up with your own
copy check out the other shows we got
over there just feel the love without
further ado
let's get spooky
[Music]
cool shot yeah good job Patrick Wilson
Patrick Wilson with the interesting
ominous upside down directing definitely
taking notes from the directors who come
before you time to keep
end of time
throw away
who died is it Josh's Mom it's Tucker
and specs in one car
that's how they would demand to be
buried they couldn't decide who got the
better plots that they just wanted one
often together it is the mom yeah
grandma she misses you too Kelly dead
people don't miss anything
there's so much you have forgotten see
you guys next weekend okay
Dalton
the POV of uh airpods
part of you
you drive him to school you have a few
weeks until all your students show up
nah he wouldn't want me to he's not the
parent you are I mean if you don't want
to then that's a different story I can't
why you're his father force him
oh his name Carl some way that you guys
could connect that's all you know he's
been gone soon so think about it are
they not together anymore that's how it
appears right now where's the movie
about their divorce let's go further
into their relationship
excuse me
do I know you
whoa I focus appreciate you coming I'm
sorry I grabbed you I got a lot on my
mind I'm sure that floods the mind with
memory theme oh no but there's always
new ones to make right other theme
people say we ruin the experiences and
movies
what are you guys talking about
oh wow
oh wow Patrick Wilson you and your
stylistic text choices
that's crazy they DH Ty Simpkins to be a
baby
and it looks flawless
is there someone behind him it sure
looks like it damn
that's fun
what the f what the hell is happening
right now
[__]
I mean uh serious gotta terrify you this
[__] is happening right now and the slow
zoom in too like
oh it's gonna be really close yeah it's
gonna be in the back seat or no it's in
the gas pipe
that was spooky uh I hope he keeps that
Steady Hand pace of direction throughout
because I like the deliberateness yeah
the patience behind the shot so far well
and the editing too has an interesting
snap about it like the combination of
the shots in the editing
cool opening shots it's making these
child drawings feel Larger than Life
[Music]
wow he remembers very iconic shots from
the previous movie
it's okay it's all in the residual
astral you know imprint
you're gonna have to pull out of your
little Funk or it's going to be a long
few days
it's well framed for these text moments
welcome to GPU
yeah I'll take one for him
what does jpu stand for just Pazuzu
University it's pretty people are shot
way better than the trailers that made
it look I know yeah mom got you this uh
Power Station thing USB port and uh
two jumper cables which are useless yeah
you say that now but you haven't been to
the finale of this movie it was a
college dormitory lots of things we can
do with jumper cables this is intense
it's what you've been working on put it
back no it's really good did you do this
for memory I see behaving like a moody
12 year old I don't know huh
I guess I didn't make the wall huh
where's that shot of you in red face
I'm sorry I haven't been around lately
of course my dad wasn't around at all
but so you should appreciate my ass I've
just been a little
foggy past few years I don't know my
brain just have you ever thought about
getting help I'm just trying to push
through yeah I don't need help this is
1956. I'm not here for your radical
ideas
everything cool Phyllis yeah
yeah I know just I thought my roommate
would be a um
um a white girl
clearly interrupted some
you really don't know me do you I mean
you really think I want to join a frat
it's just a party Dalton I mean do it
for me I drove you here man hey I heard
what Mom said at the funeral well I
still did it oh so that makes you father
of the year now after all we have done
for you why don't you become this
ungrateful little [__] uh no wonder I'll
divorce you
thanks for the ride I'll give you a one
star rating hey I like this mature
conversation yeah I didn't feel just
like Hollywood tension between them can
feel that an actor directed this way
yeah felt a lot more real I'm liking it
so far something tells me this is gonna
be like the semi Mike Flanagan version
of Insidious yeah that makes sense a
little more restrained less Bonkers yeah
story about grief forgiveness
[Music]
oh
my mother's just both so out of touch
with the truth and I mean they both are
playing a certain level of like mental
kind of fogginess well
low grade
[Music]
I have a melodica
honestly appear tonight you're in the
art school I take it yeah are you music
math I thought about music but the
artist's life is one of nomadic
instability and much gnashing of teeth
amen sister I would say that if she was
also a white woman
yes amen lady
[Music]
is that his mom's song
it's just something my mom wrote yeah
from the first we call that a callback
people
some weird [__] about you
you first on Sundays I wear monocle and
I order takeout with a British accent
that is weird
Okay sometimes I eat instant oatmeal uh
with no like water or milk or anything
it's just kind of
dry that's gross man
I was in a coma I don't remember
anything it's like I woke up one day and
a whole year had passed sure love with
that you would have won this
conversation yeah I've been afraid of
the dark seriously
sorry whatever I don't have a sleeping
mask
oh my God perfect lighting to illuminate
some spooky scenes to come to keep
ghosts obscured
[Laughter]
making sure you're getting settled in
okay I don't know what's going on with
me but
um I'm gonna find out oh
I will say they really are taking their
sweet time with the building or anything
yeah except that one lady in the back
windows
like I'm ready for Spooks now
you know
[Laughter]
your Technique is
tear it up I worked my ass off on this
piece no one will miss it wow no way
usually I go through introductions
before someone quits I didn't quit yes
you did you can go
what an excellent teaching approach
there'll be fifty thousand dollars
[Laughter]
how broken you can get
oh whoa what if yours was the only
painting she liked yes
why in the hell would you destroy a
beauty beautiful drawing
yes
I thought it was the test you must let
go of your past
shed your skin in order to grow it's
like there's themes here
with each number I want you to think
further and further further why did you
say that further concept everyone she
said further
you've got to be willing to dredge up
your ugliest innermost thoughts
all right
draw the first two movies
do it draw a cool Mondo poster we can
sell later
oh
whoa
that got me
oh is that real is it coming out of the
painting you have headphones or you feel
like you need to get out of there give
the car ball a squeeze we'll give you a
break
all aboard
what a menacing looking MRI rim
[Music]
I mean I guess if you press your ear
against it
oh he's gone into the further yeah Dr
Brauer
please
that's cool
hello hey
can you let me out
the door is open
get me out of here hello
hey
wriggle down oh
what the hell
what
it's gonna be a hand on your face
let me out
what is it always
oh
all the lights went out I got stuck in
there man I saw
uh been asleep for 15 minutes he went
right off
your MRI went perfectly you just had a
nightmare man so far the couple of
scares they've had they haven't relied
on music yeah or the I recall the
Insidious movies relying a little bit
more on music oh yeah
good news Mr Lambert I guess I was just
hoping for something real something that
could explain this
fog it's mental
do you have any history of mental
illness in your family not that I'm
aware of it's worth looking into you may
be having a mentee bee you can do
stimulate your memory matching games
like like the kids do you always play
kids games
do sometimes we can learn a lot from
kids
you gotta learn from your own kid oh man
it's a clue
the screenplay's giving you a clue
learn from your kid man
very specific blue lighting to this film
yeah
it's like the further is claving in on
them oh it's seeping in from the edges
of frame yeah well in every place in the
school is like under lit
by another 10 watt light bulb
oh my God that device is coming in handy
what happened to the light
huh the red desk lamp
just like my old sheets you better clean
that up man
you remember that's a yellie
that'll work that'll work
cool
not many room assignment today I'm in
323 now right above you so be cautious
young man unless I hear you slap your
sausage in the dead of night
you will he's a very wacky character
this one yeah
I'm excited I heard fight some ghosts we
should go
we can make fun of their khaki pants and
trust funds come on Dolphin do something
nice for your old man I offer you some
diaper pudding
um good
that is the worst themed snack to
memorialize the night that Dalton
Lambert actually has fun photo oh my god
do you think something will be in that
photo later on oh no even though no frat
is lit like the further it's a demon
party
oh no
this is Nick's room and this is Nick's
butthole cream
I'm gonna go spread this on the communal
Cropper BRB
if Nick comes up there with some I want
to Nick lock the door to this room I
especially got money
and then you you okay
you need water or something
stop whoa thank you stop
whoa close the door
see the guy who died I need some uh
supplies
hey Paige
I am Nick
oh
wait
oh Christ
eyes deceiving me no
no no
he just wants to say hi this is like the
Sixth Sense
oh
gross gross
we need to go now this is just getting
fun
nice nice bro
so sorry we were just looking for some
privacy you know we were gonna do it
yeah you should stick around we might
get drunk enough to find you attractive
even though you look like a clown
oh [__] I'm more partial to kick that
oh yeah
bro
weird inclusion of Comedy
I don't like this framing stare deeply
into the red hues
oh he naturally got there gone into your
own self-induced trance
it's a cool way to re-enter the further
officially yeah it's training like he's
lucid dreaming yeah
he's not horrified he's comfortable
oh yeah subconsciously you just must
know this place so well
it's not as good as my room
oh where's my mayonnaise
sound as I was freaky
foreign
way to terrifier you are The Spook now
oh my God
creature is it just like spindly arms I
find my mind going from uh this is
boring and repetitive from things I've
seen too oh my God that's scary
[Laughter]
I'm seeing things crazy things that
started with an art exercise dig deep
into a memory and or our subconscious I
drew this door you really need to lay
off the fried juice hey you're the one
who just experienced a weird ass yeah
I feel like I'm getting closer to
something
's getting closer to me it's approaching
he's in his underwear yes Patrickson is
either shirtless or in his underwear and
he chose to do it this time that's right
it's his call
what was with the focus on two doors you
know one of those doors is a spooky door
and the other door is a Salvation door
it's open now
doors with the focus on the door
Insidious House of Doors
are the moms alive as a dead woman you
know what I mean yeah her presence is
here oh she's trying to reach out
uh
golly
Dalton
um memory games good
so he's got some like specific ghosts
that's following him around while Dalton
is literally just hopping it out of the
further it almost feels like the further
itself is calling the Dalton while
there's still
what the hell whoa
foreign
why are you running up the stairs damn
I felt very tangible yeah this River
just feels like a guy
creepy nice
you've got the scares man like cheese
yes
welcome
good transition that's really how like
god-awful reviews I feel like it got
kind of middling review
definitely feels like there's going for
that Mike Flanagan touch yeah leading
him to create this grizzly portrait of
our father devouring his son
damn it's a metaphor dude this art
teacher is like the most app teacher for
his journey he's leading all her
students to become tortured artists yeah
of any true therapeutic help relive your
trauma and I'll see you next week
whoa
I don't want this to sound the wrong way
I usually associate Patrick Wilson as
like a dude with a six pack did he
intentionally gain weight for this I
don't know I was wondering that too yeah
he looks just more like regular dad bud
yeah I mean I can see it for the
character it makes sense
and doesn't that mean anything to you to
you a red door
is that weirder than usual
is this what happens when you go to
college you get all cryptic and [__] I
guess
bye bye little brother don't miss you at
all we got your cameo in all grown up
don't miss you
that drawing is coming together that is
Icky it's like a Leatherface or
something yeah you're not crazy at all
you are an astral projector oh my
oh my www.x YouTube channel
say hi
no okay
astral body leaves that physical body
and floats off into another realm it's
exactly what it feels like see I told
you it's cool right you're trying to
make this seem like bad editing but it's
pretty good yeah Dr Elise riniak she had
a name for this other realm she called
it the further I'm here to talk to you
about astral projection someone does not
age I know
realm and some are doomed to live the
worst mistakes of their lives over and
over and over for all eternity
life is what they crave the further you
travel the riskier the journey becomes
yeah and they can come to our world to
get it
keep a steady stride creepy YouTube
video was slowly zooming Kim Burns it
get a film student in here to record
this what if he meant something else
what if he was talking about this door
so what you want to go back and ask him
hello uh the British accent Hey where's
your monocle
what are the chances those bed sheets
are crusty probably snap like a taco
shell
I'll take the dirty floor
it's acrossier down here
it's crossed everywhere don't open don't
turn on a black light in this room
pen
seven damn is that easy for movie
purposes I guess I don't know
yeah I don't know every New Year's man
it must be a nightmare for this guy
on January 1st I don't know why
they're well Traveler
it's cool there's like some Poltergeist
elements to it
uh I'm gonna be a while
look gross
oh no no no he's in the bathroom with
him while he's doing this yep
it consumes life
Chris guys
dang
oh
no
damn it
oh no
oh God
come on
wait is she her or she must be her I
guess
oh come on
so is every movie of this character just
him rediscovering his past yeah I'm just
different parts of his past
in an attempt to protect him just a
different flavor every time I mean kinda
because like Insidious too just like
pulls back a layer of hidden yeah astral
memory then lays a new
concealer over it
[Music]
what's that your daddy I didn't know
anyone could get hurt in the real world
I can't be a part of this Dalton
and neither should you because next time
you might not wake up
I've been there I do feel like the first
like half hour of this had a pretty
solid character development and this has
been a little bit
plot beads and stuff yeah
it's like a slower repetitive version of
the other movie well yeah because now
we're in the space where we kind of just
know a lot of the stuff they're trying
to cover yeah I know like and I thought
they had some interesting Explorations
that I'm still enjoying it though I
don't want I don't want to be
misunderstood like I'm still enjoying it
but I felt like it's losing some of its
strengths
I've had this image in my mind for years
we're in a room somewhere
like a basement
hello when they frantically edit
montages of people doing very patient
activities
uh oh it's Dad Dad from part two that's
cool remember that time Dad went all
Jack Torrance the dad will devour you
yes
all I ever wanted was to be better than
my father you were you are
Dalton would disagree if it's any
consolation I can't even get him to call
me back the acting in this is really
good I would even say better than the
previous ones though yeah that is like
one of its strengths though and like Ty
Simpkins growing up over time like he's
doing a great job too I am angry I've
been angry for a long time angry at a
man that I've never met angry at a man
that jumped off the roof of a mental
hospital in 1978.
yeah
so how in the hell is he terrorizing me
here now he attacked me and Mom's he
attacked you yeah
so am I just crazy oh I didn't put that
together yeah I mean it was it was a
guess but yeah confirmed left this for
my mom the day he died
oh I wonder if he read some HP Lovecraft
this is very much like an HP Lovecraft
story his journey
oh
new number who this
save him Chris and I do like from a oh
man I do that from a psychological
standpoint that they're treating the
astral production I heard it's like a
mental illness that passes through the
the men so Dalton and I could travel to
some Dimension where we were haunted by
ghosts and goblins
or when you put it like that like the
one in those photos that haunted you
back then he told your mom she didn't
know how to help him no I help him like
you helped us
by suppressing her memories poof
you'd think they would have an
inclination that it would have something
to do with all this [__] I mean yeah I'm
divorcing you and I was too scared to
tell you the truth I'm Gonna Leave You
on your own yeah you deal with the ships
raise our kids over here
dolphin deal with it too
but you have kept us away from away from
me why just why why
our family yeah
you chased us around the house with a
goddamn baseball bat you just won me
over
that's right I forgot about that yeah
I've been lying to our children for a
decade telling them those memories
aren't real dad's not gonna hurt you
oh okay this is good this is finally
feeling like a real sequel I couldn't
live like that anymore yes okay this was
like
it might be an hour and 20 minutes
the sequel stuff I've been craving like
there we go direct continuation 100 yeah
instead of just suppress remember yeah
Dalton just sent this to me
something about a red door
what do we do
call Carl Tucker and specs yeah
oh nice cool
embrace the hammer and use it as a tool
this is a different side to the further
yeah the whole different lighting
[Music]
it's a good thing you get this memory
from third person point of view here's
Joshy
stop just stop
whoa
what the hell this is gonna actually be
them
were they trying to say that that's what
happened or it's just a play on his
memory I think it's just a play on the
memory I don't think he like put the
hammer there
I forget your mind ugh
[Music]
like the opening shot
oh wait is he not him oh
oh I would illuminate your room much
like how I illuminate your life
Afraid of the Dark anymore okay well
I mean if you want my opinion don't go
digging around in your past
oh yeah some things are just better left
buried you know why is his face actually
morphing I think the longer I mean he
just got possessed but I think the
longer possession lasts because with
Patrick Wilson they also had him with
like old lady features Dalton
hey
yo I would leave this room
you're aware enough
bring some Christmas lights with you
or evil contacts
Misty Blaster onto the bed
uh
there you go that's the stuff Dalton
we're gonna get all three generations in
the further
I forget how transport works here does
he just like walk all the way from their
house in the further to the college
we're gonna get out of here and we're
gonna get home yeah that's right I
forgot there's also like time dilation
overlap this movie semi plays like a
Nostalgia hit of the last couple
Insidious yeah remember Insidious
don't be cowards movie killer off kill
her off let's do this
thank you
he's freeing you hey
you tried to kill me they can possess
our bodies it happened to me and now
he's done it to you
yeah then you're gonna know what it
really feels like to be blamed for
something that wasn't actually your
fault yeah you got a little [__]
and now you can think of me Swinging The
Hammer to save you
oh yeah
oh cool
it Juiced up his mouth effects it's the
red door
ew
[Music]
so they just seeped into the real world
now
that's
what appears to be happening right now
yeah
Dad please
this ends with me
you go
oh God
maybe the point is to not close the door
I feel like that's that's probably where
we're headed this ends with me
hey I called it yeah everyone look at me
[Music]
that's sad
oh and it's still kind of like the
painting in its earlier form okay
[Music]
oh yeah painted shut interesting
ugh
[Applause]
say something cool Adam
that's a cool visual yeah that was
really cool visual burn it forget about
it no no forgetting it doesn't work we
need to remember
even the things that hurt
themes dad
[Music]
I think Patrick Wilson did a really
great job directing I hope he gets an
opportunity to dress like an original
script yeah
oh
be the light to guide you home
okay
plot toast it's not him oh no he kills
his wife
Dalton
Dalton only attend that one class yep
yeah
it's a really relaxed uh structure in
terms of how many units you need per
semester hey we're a happy family again
guys hey we're getting back together and
Chris lives with us now see you next
Friday
come a little earlier if you want join
us for dinner yeah I'd like that hey
thanks I do think that they missed out
on a big thing with not making it a
little bit more about them I mean yeah I
do think they really missed out on that
I think the way he's handled the
directing of it is really great it's
it's more like
I appreciate the efforts of the script a
lot lovely home oh wait thanks
do you live here I hope so is it her I
guess I've just lost in memories
they can flood the mine yes
it's her voice
[Music]
hear that woman on YouTube
I know your mother you have a bright
future ahead
you and Dalton
keep a steady stride Josh
oh nice I'm just gonna go tell that MRI
doctor he's a quack yeah there was [__]
wrong with me
[Music]
Devil Woman
dad made the wall you think got to have
wow
I made the wall
not bad
cinematic image
all right Patrick Wilson singing
is it actually his voice yeah he he
collabed with uh that band called ghost
for this cover song apparently
a little self-indulgent here
I know you sang in The Conjuring too but
you don't have to do it every minute
like I'm directing this I'm singing yeah
I stopped getting naked in movies so now
I'm gonna sing
no he's got a lovely voice he does he
does but we could talk about the movie
while he sings this yeah yeah
um I enjoyed that quite a bit you know
like I I feel like one thing coming into
this movie for me that that I had to
catch myself on was like you know you
get to part five and something and
you're like okay here we go you know I'm
not expecting like necessarily greatness
but remembering back over the franchise
I've liked pretty much every Insidious
movie and I feel like this keeps up a
lot of the qualities that even like the
mid chapters you know three and four
that people don't sort of look as fondly
on like those movies both to me had like
charms I thought three was really light
probably but I feel like just as we've
got I must look well it's I think it got
good reviews and I think people were
pretty pleased generally I am looking
John you talk while I look I would
assert the idea that as we remove
ourselves further in time people
probably further on the first two movies
Focus what Greg does his Interruption
the definitive chapters and then three
and four being more auxiliary uh for
various reasons I mean three you had uh
lee 1l's directorial debut uh which was
certainly you know fun and Punchy and
that movie managed to you know create
something yeah that's like a little
elevated from what the idea would have
you kind of expecting especially based
on the idea that it is like the third in
a franchise and so here coming into this
part of me yeah was just sort of like
okay this is a lot of kind of different
Stakes Patrick Wilson's directorial
debut we're on Insidious freaking five
now yeah okay so Insidious two is 39
wowie and cities three is 57 oh oh okay
well then I'm uh I must be mistaken
oh
[Music]
cute little post credits there the door
will return
um but yeah I don't know before I before
I go too far what would you think sir
um now that we've discovered that
everyone apparently loves three a lot
more than part two well actually this
has the same Rotten Tomatoes score as
part two okay interesting yeah
people don't love that Lambert family I
guess that's the first one
I think part two is one of those that's
been appreciated in Morris time went on
sure I remembered I never rewatched it
because I remember not really liking it
that much okay maybe I was in the
minority at the time like I liked part
two and part two certainly crazier and
it goes after different movie tributes
and stuff like that but I thought it was
a step down for sure
no
yeah uh I I mean I I feel like I'm uh I
imagine most of our commentary made this
reaction who knows
um but I feel like I was making it
pretty clear how it was really feeling
about it throughout uh I do think that
the movie
uh there are there are things that I
would find myself going like what is
resonating more with me here on my
subjective viewing experience
because there's a lot here that
ultimately when you when you pull it
back you go this is a lot of this is
just mainly
remember them remembering the first
couple movies but in a really deliberate
film yeah you know yeah like a slower
film without the punch of a Lee one out
direction or a James wand Direction yeah
it's not going for as much of a fun
house tone it's going very much for like
a creeping slowly unfolding kind of
thing but with the true emotional
substance not really there until the
finale and the First Act and it's the
mid and act two is mainly like
slow deliberate creep stuff but loses a
lot of that Nuance that is present in
the First Act in the third act and I
think what it was really seeing for me
it's like the father-son story I think
they should have had them interacting a
little bit more together instead of
telling just to completely separate plot
lines with them and
because then it's just them on their own
going I'm starting to remember the first
movies you know yeah that's what they're
essentially doing with a little bit of
Patrick Wilson going my dad and and then
uh
and then I think they should have dealt
more I was like I loved what they just
included it's so late if they did deal
with that of of like oh they're divorced
what happened you know yeah and them
really dealing with the repercussions of
what the dad did in the second movie you
know and
and the kid and it's like they only had
that with Dalton who had this angst
about it instead of the other kids and
I'm like oh there's there seems like
there was a more I feel like there could
have been a way more interesting movie
while still doing like because like I
said the Patrick Wilson's directing I
thought was really good I thought the
shots look great like on the trailers it
looked like some weird straight to DVD
[__] yeah and and when watching the
actual movie like no this looks this
looks really good yeah it's great
looking film and and it's well edited
he's got a great sense of Aura and tone
and yeah it's well edited and the scares
are actually quality I thought they were
good quality scares the only thing that
kind of hampers it is at times you're
like yeah this is
since the other movies yeah just shot
different it's the same it's the like
we're just redoing the same kind of
scare but just a different type of
Direction on it which it's
understandable for a sequel to Insidious
and going back into the further but the
plot context I thought could have just
been so much more Dynamic and and just
overall like it's the most simplistic
term just way more engaging if they did
have more of that uh interaction where
that's where the real meat of the story
was and then and clearly that's what the
movie's even saying at the end here but
they introduce it so late yeah as a
thing that like oh that would have just
made a more interesting movie if this is
what they're dealing with instead of
like that same beat all over again what
I have a thing from my past and I'm
gonna like we're doing this we're doing
it again just just with a different mood
wrapped around it you know yeah it's
interesting like I admire the choice and
I think there I think yeah it's like I
can imagine an alternate version of this
script where you have them still
learning about the situation and filling
in the the gaps for themselves on their
own but there was something I said early
on and I think we even joked about it
the whole like it was gonna be an
awkward few days if we're not talking to
each other and part of me was like if
you had it such that he was gonna be
however far away you know the school is
from where they live like okay he's
gonna be there for like a week or
something so it's like they could get
distance from each other but be very
close together for some of the emotional
beats of this because yeah it's like
without that in the middle you do feel
like okay we're kind of
it's not as good as like the sum of its
parts in that section because yeah it's
like it's they're doing fine work
watching the individual plot lines
layout but then that stuff becomes a lot
more nuts and bolts and a lot more
creeping toward things that we already
kind of know are coming I guess well
it's because when you when you get that
final moments uh when he when he finally
meets up with Rose Byrne that actually
introduces a tangible ingredient of
something they have to overcome yeah
on an emotional core level on a physical
level
whereas most of the movie prior to like
the last 20 minutes yeah is that I'm
just I'm trying to remember yeah
something yeah yeah yeah and I gotta
gotta go in and out of the further to
get there I guess yeah and and we know
them and the thing is it's not that Mis
it's not mysterious yeah because we know
the mystery we know what they're trying
to unpack we know the answer so it's not
as interesting as it looks you know and
if you'd had him uncovering like I like
the whole thing with the painting and
the way it's like slowly taking shape
and like oh there's a face and it's all
you know vague and distorted like I feel
like there would have been a way maybe
to amplify the effects of him finally
realizing oh [__] that's dad the memory
is all coming back in a situation where
Patrick Wilson as a character is a bit
closer in proximity and closer in terms
of just like the direct link between
their two stories as they unfold or
something like that like yeah it's I I
liked where it got to and I thought
those scenes were great and like for her
brief appearances I thought Rose Byrne
did a terrific job and that's something
I remember about the first movie too is
they had a really nice sense of like
cross talk with each other and like
those kind of intimate family Vibes they
missed that I think it's I think that's
a missing ingredient here yeah
um yeah it's weird it's like it makes
sense as to why these things would
happen and I thought it was funny we're
sitting there going like yeah you know
you kind of left him a lot well he did
try to like Massacre your whole family
this has been very very traumatic but at
the same time having it it's weird it's
like I admire the choice of this being
the father-son story mostly focusing on
them I like the choice that they have at
least the one brother uh sort of at
least kind of involved on the periphery
but there is something about like that
family unit I feel like we experienced
them mostly in the memorial and then in
flashback and it would have been nice to
have like that family unit a little more
vital throughout or something yeah yeah
because I like I said the
the purpose to of of tuber the purpose
to remember
I think we needed a little bit of
clarity on like if you think about the
first movie
the purpose to remember is I gotta get
my son out of where he's trapped he's
not in a coma yeah you know yeah I have
to save him yeah
um it's not just about remembering for
remembering sake because my mind is
bothered by some [__] and like you need
that actual thing to thrust the movie
forward and so it does feel as great as
the movie actually looks and as solid as
the acting is uh from everyone here
and I like and like I like some of the
deeper nuances they're aiming for for
the commentary on mental health and
repression and all that jazz like it's a
more
um at times on the nose but I think for
the most part I'm a more
uh I guess a more mature handling of it
than the previous ones it's the rare
movie like this where I feel like the
subtext is like really well intact and
then just some of like the actual
immediate plot beats like could do
better accentuating that yeah yeah yeah
yeah because especially
like for my benefit I have only I
haven't really I don't I've only seen
the second one once and I I think I've
seen the first one twice yes I must have
because I saw it at home I saw it in the
theaters and then when we saw the second
one I think we went to a double feature
right yeah yeah I remember that when
that happened and it didn't help because
the second one you know like the second
one
oh yeah don't worry it's not as bad as
the time I saw all the five die hards in
the same day sure because that Marathon
got really challenging
yes that's like the main missing thing
for me was
um the potential of the movie really
finally became Crystal Clear when she
introduced that I'm like oh I've only
just been a much more interesting film
yeah if it was like you know you try to
do something or like the kids are all
like if if he was just like shunned from
the family and the kid because I only
got the sense that Dalton had an issue
with him I didn't get the sense the
other kids had an issue with like or at
least the other son it makes sense for
Cali or whatever the like the daughters
was not involved in it no this is my all
intents and purpose she's a baby right
in the first round yeah and so unless
it's like truly let genetic thing but
yeah it's like Foster should at least
have some
uh I don't know yeah I didn't read as
much like a trauma and especially when
he comes in on the both of them it just
seemed like oh it's just Mom and Dad or
if there was like a thing of like where
did we go wrong like Patrick Wilson
doesn't know and like Rose Byrne is like
there's like an anguishing conflict
about
like I I want to be able to talk to you
about this but I I can't it's you know
you can't it's dangerous you know like I
was like damn there's such a meaty thing
there yes because I didn't quite get
like what the point of them trying to
remember other than was like okay is the
further just trying to seep back in and
it's like it had it had its character
arcs and psychological things on its
mind but in terms of making the actual
journey through it more Dynamic
especially on an Insidious level it
Grant I haven't seen the fourth one so I
don't know how like terrible then that's
about what everyone said I mean I
thought it was it's probably I know it's
I know it's like the one that I thought
it was pretty decent I know it's the one
that people like the least um I've never
seen that one yeah I mean it's I I think
just in a nutshell it's still in fitting
with the like oh okay this is going for
some emotionally uh motivated stuff and
then lots of jump scares and yada yada
it's probably the most sort of uh side
questy feeling of all of them it's I
like that one because it was like about
Elise and it was like her movie to lead
uh which I thought was new but the
opening of this film that was the actual
ending of part two
I'm looking at the footage of them I
don't know that's a lot of the best
de-aging and digital creation of Thai
Simpkins yeah totally oh because I don't
remember that at all
um
because yeah to repress that
because yeah like I like the context of
that of oh what happens when you just
try to repress it
um yeah instead of like you you would
this was a natural fitting plot for that
but it just ultimately does feel
repetitive
um but no I mean other than me just
sounding repetitive here uh I think Ty
Simpkins is great I actually enjoyed the
presence of that new girl Chris was
great yeah I thought she was fun and
brought life to it and her entire
Simpkins had a great back and forth and
I like their friendship well I like that
I found that very endearing even if that
part even if the middle of the movie
does kind of sag under the weight of
like we're just kind of running around
and figuring stuff out and trying to
remember things like I really like their
Rapport I thought her involvement with
the plot was relatively conscientious in
terms of just how characters respond to
things overall
um and and yeah like I I really
appreciated
um
or you know what I think could have
could have helped I don't know I feel
like because they had the whole divorce
thing it's like you could have kind of
opened up throughout the middle I feel
like you could have involved Rose Byrne
to a point where it's like she and
Patrick Wilson are trying to figure this
out together because he's clearly trying
to make progress on this
um I don't know yeah it's like it's like
if you just moved the crest into act
three further back to being there for
act two or something yeah if they
learned all that [__] halfway through
and then we started again because then
it's parts of the finale especially
because it seems like the movie's gonna
be when it first starts off it seems
like it's going to be an even
displacement even placement of scenes
between Patrick Wilson and Ty Simpkins
yeah and then at a certain point it's
like it's like mainly Ty Simpkins yes
sometimes it's magic Wilson if you'd had
him and her figuring this [__] out and
then like or even him testing was
calling Rose Byrne you know
I don't know why they didn't involve her
it feels like a scheduling thing she's
like barely in this movie yeah but she's
clearly as committed as she's been
before and I feel like there could have
been a greater enhancement of it's funny
that it's one of those reviews where I'm
like I like most everything about this
movie generally but it does kind of
leave you thinking about a couple ways
in which it could have been great and
yeah it's like I think they could have
also made more out of the sense of
distance if you'd had those Stakes kind
of going sooner because it's like you've
got Patrick Wilson doing his astral
experience in one place and then Dalton
in a different location and that is neat
as it's presented but I think could have
been like a much grander source of
tension or something especially if
you've got the family sort of I don't
know you'd have that extra layer of
their relationship reforming and maybe
them getting past some trauma the family
kind of confronting this and
strengthening together and then rather
that being like the sort of end
destination you could have that be part
of their Journey as we then get to this
yet to prong sort of further Journey
um but either way yeah I really liked uh
the returning cast Chris was great
um you know and the different flourishes
of like the demons the Tiny Tim stuff
coming back there's like not much in the
way of like further ghosts and things
but I always enjoy the aesthetic of the
further nice to see Tucker in specs for
a second
at least for a second I mean like it's
it's it's their franchise altogether in
a lot of ways I feel like it's been her
franchise up until this point so this
was kind of a neat sort of torch pass or
or at least a way to like wrap it up in
a way it's like Beyond her
um and yeah like I thought it's funny it
is something I notice in movies of like
when they have like art and artists and
students and and Fine Arts and things
like that like it can be kind of Hit or
Miss in terms of like what really just
reads authentically and I thought they
had a lot of like really neat art
designs in this
um and yeah it's like for what it is I
appreciate it it's like I like the
script they came up with and the story
they come up with and it didn't seem
like anything was lazy necessarily but
it does feel like this is one option out
of a few options for how to present the
story I guess
yeah
and I don't remember who they said was
credited on the script but I'm looking
it up right now but yeah like I thought
Scott teams I've heard that name I think
is a Conjuring writer or something like
that he did Halloween kills
red face dies tonight
uh he did Fire Starter oh good
that was well received I mean His
Highest ones when we were called that
Evening Sun I don't know what this is
though okay I mean I thought this was a
a nicely done directed as well
there's a solid like as far as like
scripts I have gripes about go I thought
this was like you know it breathed nice
this themes are a bit loud but they're
there and they make a lot of sense and I
do appreciate the yeah just the
rumination on like generational
inherited traumas mental illness Etc the
way that comes out through ART
um and I feel like that's kind of its
own sort of trophy environment is like
the big sort of cavernous art class room
where we're gonna do a lot of like dark
emotional work and stuff and then the
cutting back and forth and the painting
actually being part of the experience
there like this is a bit maybe muddier
in terms of like the rules of the
further because too you have like the
scene where the demons are just all
grabbing Chris and you're like what are
the wait what exactly how does this work
well I think that there was a an element
of depth that they were teasing us with
and I just think that depth gets so lost
yeah into just remember again I'm sorry
I don't mean literal fact finders yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um that's and and so to me that's where
my disappointment of it comes in because
that was like the first 23 minutes I was
like oh you know there's something
really interesting here yeah and then
never mind yeah yeah we're gonna we're
gonna divide the family up and then
we're gonna divide the two core units of
the family up and then we're gonna have
like parallel plot lines until we get
back to yeah meshing again yeah yeah
because because even because I even feel
like Patrick Wilson's Journeys um
hampered by
he doesn't remember to like the last
until he meets about the Rose Burns like
he's back in the further he's handling
I'm like oh well now he just got like we
skipped over a whole journey that's what
I'm saying yeah it's like if you'd
involved her with the medical situation
and his mind you know attenuation games
and stuff like that like
I don't know yeah I think you could have
a lot more gradually
developed these themes rather than it
feeling like oh yeah they kicked uh back
into gear all of a sudden when we got
like this big burst of breakthrough
character energy yeah yeah because I'm
not even here being like Oh I wanted
more fun scary stuff you know uh like I
like the fun scary stuff and I think
it's hideous that's one of its earmarks
so perhaps that is a thing that is if it
can be a little listless I imagine uh
for people when it comes to this movie
but for myself
I don't know I'm I I tend to be more of
like a Mike Flanagan lover uh this is
where I'm just like yeah just be
deep dark drama movies
for what this is I thought it it was I
think it postures as that as a spook
house as a deep dark as a deep drama
sure yeah sure sure there are certainly
better choices they could have made if
they really wanted this to be a deep
dark drama and uh and that thing that
goes back to the script though yeah yeah
yeah totally because it's it's excuse I
can see it in that mechanic of like its
reasons to get them alone isolated and
into situations where you can have these
tents looking around jump scare kind of
moments that we all associate with it's
harder to do that in a group scenario
um and and yeah but I mean for whatever
friction is caused by the amount of
depth or not the script is going for I
thought the horror moments the horror
Aesthetics the the characters we see
like the dead frat guy
um you know the moments in the further
with the fog and the crazy rooms like I
of that stuff all still carried the aura
and I thought the actual scare moments
were all pretty well effective because
two I remember especially at the height
of you know the sort of more recent
ghost haunting movie boom it started to
become a meme to me like especially
watching like the original nun trailer
or even Insidious 4 you're like okay so
how many different versions of like
let's pan back and forth and try and
misdirect your eye and all that stuff
before we eventually jump out at you can
we do and I thought this managed to have
interesting fun jump scares that didn't
feel like they were trying too hard or
forced to bend over backwards I think
that's a good credit to give the movie
was it
nor does it feel like just some
afterthought like I like the MRI scare a
lot yeah it lets you live in that moment
yeah without it again I respected when
they didn't rely on music there was good
jump scares there's effective stuff here
and I like that Patrick Wilson was
here to Showcase his directing skills
without trying to be like I'm I want to
I want to make you a terrifying film
yeah it's like he clearly learns stuff
and the the scares and the amount of
horror stuff like proportionately I
think matches the type of story this
particular movie is well half of his
films he made what James wants so yeah
he must have learned and learned a lot
about using Hot Heads you learn a lot
about moving camera I believe five
movies at least right It's gotta be five
that's your Insidious two conjurings and
an Aquaman yeah so he's done five I mean
unless there's one I'm forgetting that
James won directed but he's oh well I
mean he's the lost kingdom um but
if that ever sees the legend yeah it
really doesn't like him he does a
[__] boy yeah yeah that's the dude
yeah James really likes working with
this guy yeah
it's like number one guy right there
when I cast you in two very similar
franchises and then take you on my
Blockbuster Adventure yeah that's kind
of crazy yeah it really really does get
along with that guy yeah
hey you know you find your Muse and uh
James Salon found Patrick Wilson
alrighty
um
it's pretty good leave us your thoughts
what did you guys think are you in
cities fan did this movie live up to
your expectations where would you rank
it in the pantheon of insidii leave us
your thoughts and before we get out of
here let's do up
Gabriel
burn I'm assuming your last name is burn
because Rose Burn is in this movie
Booyah and if there's anybody I'd love
to come home to in a state of traumatic
distress to be comforted by Gabriel
that'd be you I feel like you could calm
me you could provide me with the
emotional and intellectual details to
soothe my quandary and put me back on
the path toward the light does anyone
call you Gabby Gaby gab Gabe Gabriel
Gibby ooh Gibby I like Gibby huh you
know there's other variations in her
name like gabrian Gabriella Gabrielle
Gabriel gavril gavril that's a cool one
huh anyone call you that let's try one
more time Gabby Gaby Gabe Gabriel Gibby
gabrin Gabriela Gabriel Gabrielle
Gabriel say that 50 times fast jeez get
Gibby get I can just keep coming back
Gabby gabri that's the one I wanted
Gibby
how many of these names make uh
shortening like negate the point of
shortening a name by making it more
complicated choose your favorite
nickname Gabriel do you have one is it
just Gabe you should get some more
original like Gibby or uh you know or
give me give me Gabriel gaberson
whatever it is you let us know what you
want to be called and uh and we will
neither assume you religious nor a
simple Gabriel nor Gabe you will be the
most uniquely named person at this
patreon so uh keep on the straight and
narrow stay out of the astral plane and
uh stay pledged though in fact if you
want to Pledge on this plane and pledge
in the astral plane just to cover
yourself for all of time to come it's a
good idea but anyway we love you here
love you love you Gabriel Gabby Gabriel
[Music]